-Today's Friday,
and that's usually
when I catch up with
some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
return some e-mails,
and, of course, I send out
thank-you notes.
And I was just...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...running a bit behind.
I thought, today,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I would just like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes.
Is that cool?
[ Audience cheers ]
Thank you very much.
James, can I get some
thank-you-note-writing music,
please?
Thank you so much.
[ Somber piano music playing ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-He forgot his tie again.
[ Music stops ]
Mm.
[ Music resumes ]
"Thank you,
Trump indictment protests,
for looking like one guy decided
to dry his beach towels
in front of Trump Tower."
[ Music stops ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
There are four there.
[ Music resumes ]
"Thank you, TikTok stars
marching in Washington,
for being the first time
a protest chant ends with,
'Sheeeesh!'"
[ Music stops ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Music resumes ]
"Thank you, spring, for being
when the flowers bloom,
the birds sing, and the bears
come out of hibernation
to look for cocaine."
[ Music stops ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Music resumes ]
"Thank you, allergy medicine,
for being the reason
I don't sneeze
through my kid's recital,
but snore through it instead."
[ Music stops ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
[ Music resumes ]
"Thank you, barbed wire, for not
going by your other name,
Evil Slinky."
[ Music stops ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Drum beat ]
That's a jam.
Come on, man.
[ Piano music resumes ]
"Thank you, 'John Wick 4,'
'Shazam! 2,'
'Scream VI,' and 'Creed III,'
for sounding more like
a bingo card
than a weekend at the movies."
Oh, I got it! Bingo!
[ Music stops ]
[ Music resumes ]
"Thank you, birdhouses,
for being nature's Airbnbs."
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank-you notes.